[Música]
muy buenas tardes
cuando se cierra una puerta se abre una
ventana esta famosa frase puede reflejar
el momento en el cual muchos estudiantes
del colegio secundario reciben su
diploma cerrando así una importante
etapa de sus vidas para inmediatamente
comenzar con otra etapa muy importante
como lo es la vida en la universidad
todos los ingresantes deben pasar por un
montón de etapas previas tales como por
ejemplo trámites y mucho papelería en el
caso de algunas universidades como la
universidad tecnológica nacional
exámenes de ingreso una preciosa foto
carne en la cual va a estar pegada en la
portada de las libretas hasta el día que
se reciban más de una deseando haberse
arreglado un poco más por ejemplo en mi
foto carne estoy totalmente rapado y con
una camiseta de racing pero bueno más
allá del detalle una vez pasados todos
estos pasos previos y con la ansiedad de
estar por fin estudiando algo que nos
gusta que nos llamó la atención o que
simplemente le queremos dar una
oportunidad tarde o temprano todos nos
topamos con el desencadenante de muchos
de los problemas de la vida
universitaria
para que el que no está entendiendo lo
que me estoy refiriendo no haga alusión
a nada más ni nada menos que al plan de
estudios de la carrera aquí en pantalla
podemos observar por ejemplo el plan de
estudios de la carrera ingeniería
química de acá de la utm
créanme puede parecer un simple papel
pero este pequeño endemoniado es el
disparador de todos los problemas porque
a ver pensamos un poco un papel es
simplemente hizo un papel ustedes lo
deben tener ahí al alcance de sus manos
no emite opinión no emite comentarios
pero créanme cuando les digo que este
pequeñín ejerce poderes casi
sobrenaturales sobre los estudiantes y
les hace pensar muchas cosas locas tales
como por ejemplo si ahí mismo dice que
mi primer año tiene ocho materias sí o
sí tengo que hacer ocho materias en mi
primer año o de lo contrario se van a
secar los océanos
sí ahí mismo dice que física 2 hay que
hacerla en el segundo año en el segundo
cuatrimestre no queda otra si o si te
ocasión en el segundo año del segundo
cuatrimestre de lo contrario puede
llegar a generarse un pequeño gran
desbalance en la fuerza y puede llegar a
caer un meteorito en mi casa o algo así
o usted se está riendo atrás de la
pantalla pero yo ese último pensamiento
lo tuve más de una oportunidad es
entonces cuando comienza a faltarnos el
tiempo comienzan las noches de desvelo
estudiando y leyendo y leyendo y el
tiempo nunca alcanza para cuando nos
queremos dar cuenta estamos ante el
siguiente escenario colectivo lleno
ahora pico no estamos sentados estamos
parados con el cuaderno en mano sin
estar agarrados de nada soportados por
la presión de cuatro o cinco personas a
nuestro alrededor que dejen que leamos
alguna oración suelta antes de llegar al
examen a ver si podemos rajar una
porción más de conocimiento
es entonces cuando ahí se genera el
primer paso a una vorágine de
pensamientos que sólo incluyen cosas
relacionadas con la universidad
cuando antes había un hermoso partido de
fútbol usado de la tarde con amigos
ahora debemos quedarnos en casa haciendo
ejercicios de exámenes viejos
cuando antes no se estábamos cansados
llegábamos de alguna actividad y
queríamos ver películas en netflix no no
no no no tenemos un pilón de informes de
laboratorio impostergables les aseguro
para cuando se quieran dar cuenta
pasaron de tener de pareja a su propia
pareja y no ahora tienen de pareja al
chang para química o al leithold para
cálculo
y todas estas cuestiones se magnifican
ante el primer tropezón el primer
informe rechazado el primer parcial
desaprobado la primer materia que uno
debe re cursar
ante la imposibilidad de poder cumplir a
rajatabla con lo que nos dice el plan de
estudios nos entran dudas inseguridades
no es novedad que las mayores tasas de
abandono de la enseñanza universitaria
se den los primeros dos años de la
carrera generalmente la verdad es que
películas como american pay nos muestran
una versión un tanto distorsionada de lo
que es la vida del estudiante
universitario y esto que les acabo de
comentar ocurre en múltiples carreras
ingeniería abogacía medicina y no sólo
acá en argentina sino en todas partes
del mundo ahora bien quiero detenerme un
momento en el caso de christopher
pressmart cris estudiante de la
universidad estatal de illinois jugador
de fútbol y con la fortuna de haber
formado una hermosa pareja la verdad que
él encontró un balance en estos tres
ejes véase el estudio su vida amorosa el
deporte y su familia lo veía muy
contento porque él sentía realizado con
cada una de estas actividades o ejes
lamentablemente la universidad no lo
seleccionó para el equipo de fútbol y
encima su pareja lo dejó de estos tres
ejes tan importantes para su vida chris
solo se quedó con el estudio recuerden
el balance en la fuerza que les
comentabas algunos momentos no se generó
porque chris comenzó a rendir más todos
sus exámenes sino porque en el momento
más pesado de su vida chris solo contaba
con el estudio y las exigencias que él
mismo se impuso para cumplir pero bueno
no no importa debemos cumplir con el
plan de estudios a como dé lugar sin
importar el contexto los tiempos tenemos
que cumplir
si les interesa saber qué es de la vida
de chris hoy lamentablemente chris se
quitó la vida en el año 2014 teniendo
tan solo 18 años de vida
pero si les dijera que chris no es el
único y si les dijera que en este
preciso momento hay un gran potencial de
que ocurran tragedias semejantes
como a mí me gustan mucho los números
quiero brindarles un par de estadísticas
un poco más palpables un estudio hecho
en eeuu por la associated press
entrevistando estudiantes de más de tres
docenas de casas de estudio públicas
determinó que los estudiantes de
dedicación completa entre 18 y 22 años
más o menos que tuvieron problemas o
pensamientos serios sobre el suicidio
incremento de un 66 8% entre los años
2012 a 2013 es más desde el año 2014 la
cantidad de estudiantes que pidió algún
tipo de asistencia terapéutica a estas
distintas casas de estudio aumentó en un
35 por ciento siendo que sólo aumentó en
un 5% las inscripciones estas mismas
universidades y déjenme decirles una
cosa como aparece ahora en pantalla la
situación de la pandemia por kobe 19 no
eso más que agravar la situación un
estudio hecho por la facultad de
psicología de leus es a estudiantes de
múltiples carreras determinó que el 80
por ciento de esos estudiantes
signo de ansiedad el 78 rasgos de algún
tipo de depresión siendo la más notoria
depresión moderada el 48% de iu notaba
signos de estrés altamente
significativos y el 65% dijo haber
tenido problemas para conciliar el sueño
en algún momento del pasado 2020 yo lo
viví
quieren saber qué es lo más llamativo de
este estudio las preocupaciones que
dispararon esta ansiedad y depresión
fueron fundamentalmente de dos tipos el
primer tipo era de índole económico no
estar a gusto con su trabajo no tener un
trabajo estable o no poder llegar
cómodos a fin de mes y el segundo tipo
eran las preocupaciones de índole social
no poder ver a su familia y amigos y
usted detrás de la pantalla se pueden
estar preguntando las preocupaciones por
enfermarse de kobe o que la cuarentena
que no pueden aprender de manera óptima
déjeme decirles no eran para nada
abundantes entonces qué es lo que está
ocurriendo en esta situación imaginemos
el siguiente escenario tenemos una
bonita balanza con igual peso a ambos
lados si comenzamos a ponerle más peso a
uno de los lados se va a generar un
pequeño desbalance no si además no sólo
le ponemos peso a uno de los lados sino
que comenzamos a quitarle peso al lado
contrario el desbalance va a ser mucho
más marcado y la balanza incluso puede
llegar a romperse
que lo que está ocurriendo es lo que les
quiero decir
cuando nuestras decisiones hacen que le
quitemos peso a alguno de los ejes de
nuestra vida podemos llegar a entrar en
un malestar y que erróneamente se lo
aboquemos a ponerle peso al lado
contrario
y déjenme decirles una cosa esto es
altamente silencioso y progresivo
déjenme mostrarle algunos ejemplos
no la verdad es que hoy no puedo ir a
natación mira todo lo que tengo para
estudiar no no pasa nada si no voy hoy
la verdad que vengo viendo todos estos
meses no pasa nada
yo ya sé que hoy nos íbamos a juntar con
los amigos por el cumpleaños de mi mejor
amigo pero la verdad es que tengo mucho
para estudiar y si mañana no me levanto
temprano no llego le voy a mandar un
mensaje y nos vemos en otra junta del
mea saber entender
bueno después del parcial del jueves le
mando mensaje a mi novia le digo que
vamos a tomar un helado el fin de semana
había arreglado con mis compañeros hacer
formas de laboratorio que faltaban bueno
no importa total el cuatrimestre ya está
por terminar no importa no nos vemos a
su mes pero ya me vas a ver entender que
le hace una mancha más al tigre un fin
de semana más un fin de semana menos
estas frases comentarios que suenan así
un poco sacados de la galera son cosas
que me dije a mí mismo en determinado
momento de la carrera adoptando esa
bandera de solo prestar la
atención a cosas del estudio total el
resto siempre va a estar ahí
pues déjeme decirle una cosa por motivos
de la pandemia que hoy 19 pasaron seis
meses hasta que volví a ver a mi pareja
un año hasta que volvió a verle la cara
a mis amigos quienes incluso hasta el
día de hoy que no puede retomar con
natación la verdad es que por más
planificada e ideada que tengamos
nuestra vida en nuestra cabeza puede
llegar a algo externo incontrolable como
lo fue en este caso para muchos de
nosotros el commit 19 que nos patee el
tablero y nos tire toda esa organización
al aire
y es por eso que si alguno de los
oyentes se sintió identificado con algo
de todo lo que vengo diciendo tengo algo
muy importante que decirles si ustedes
se sienten con un malestar incómodos con
alguna situación relacionada con el
estudio lo primero que deben hacer es
charlar dialogar comentárselo a sus
personas de confianza a sus seres
queridos estoy seguro que más de uno se
va agarrar la cabeza cuando empiecen a
hablarles de integrales derivadas
conceptos de química que deben tener en
polvo décimos del secundario pero
también les puedo asegurar con un cien
por ciento de eficacia que todos ellos
los quieren ver bien en plenitud
como les comentaba anteriormente estas
cosas suelen ser muy silenciosas y la
verdad es que si no las charlas pueden
llegar a incurrir en que sus seres
queridos no se den cuenta por lo que
están pasando imaginemos el siguiente
escenario creo que todos lo van a saber
entender tenemos un hermoso tanque de
agua al cual comenzamos a llenar lo
llenamos lo llenamos lesionamos lo
llenamos y ahora nos llenamos va a
llegar un momento en el cual las
personas de afuera van a detectar fugas
y puede que ser que estemos a tan solo
unos momentos de una explosión
si todos sus problemas se generan por no
poder cumplir a rajatabla con el bendito
plan de estudios sencillos a su propio
plan de estudios
hace un tiempo me puse a pensar que
todos nosotros utilizamos de manera
totalmente indiscriminada el término
carrera universitaria carrera
universitaria supone que alguien tiene
que correr miran yo me tomé la molestia
todo este último fin de semana que pasó
investigando investigando investigando
páginas de los juegos olímpicos
oficiales y les puedo asegurar que
ninguna consideran recibimientos
universitarios como disciplina olímpica
la verdad el siguiente yo tuve la
oportunidad de hablar con muchos
compañeros que no sólo estudian sino que
además trabajan full time con lo cual no
pueden hacer un montón de materias por
año y dada la charla les puedo asegurar
que cuando mencionaba o mi edad o las
materias que estaba haciendo en ese
momento la cara de esas personas se
transformaba con tan sólo mirarlos a los
ojos
podía sentir su angustia
la realidad es la siguiente ningún
alumno es más o menos que ningún otro
por hacer más rápido o más lento la
carrera comillas el problema está cuando
siento ciertos pensamientos entran a
nuestra cabeza y nos generan un
desbalance en nuestro corazón
pensamientos del estilo hay este
compañero si puedo hacer ocho materias
el año pasado y yo la verdad que sólo
puedo hacer tres tengo un quilombo en
casa mi trabajo estoy totalmente
desesperado esos son los pensamientos
que nos generan el desbalance en la
fuerza ustedes se pueden preguntar
detrás de la pantalla y cómo podemos
balancear esta situación si se quiere el
primer paso es entender el siguiente
concepto
la facultad debe ser una parte de sus
vidas y su vida no tiene que ser la
facultad
esta misma frase me la dijo ya por la
noche de los tiempos no voy a decir años
para no de la eternidad mi profesor del
curso de ingreso en una de sus últimas
clases en ese momento la verdad que yo
no entendí lo que me quiso transmitir
pero hoy en día estando un pasito de
recibirme
creo que esto con esta frase condensa un
poco de todo lo que vengo diciendo la
realidad es que si sienten que por hacer
esas ocho materias por año ustedes van a
dejar de lado a su familia a sus amigos
a su propia pareja
déjenme contarles un secreto acaba
no tienen por qué hacer esas ocho
materias por año gente saben algo la
facultad va a seguir ahí los libros van
a seguir ahí los docentes los cuadernos
pero si no comenzamos a prestar la
atención a nuestros malestares
lamentablemente como le pasó a chris uno
llegará a ser nosotros los que no
estemos ahí
mi madre siempre me dijo y de hecho me
sigue diciendo que la salud es lo más
importante y que sin ella no vamos a
ningún lado y salud también incluye
nuestros pensamientos y sentimientos les
digo por experiencia propia que no sirve
de nada quedarse tardes soleadas de
domingo haciendo ejercicios con fotos
borrosas parciales de 1998 o quedarse en
el colectivo queriendo hacer un
ejercicio más que se te rompe la punta
del lápiz y se perdió el sacapuntas
tenido que experimentar los olores más
exóticos del universo para promocionar
ni diez ni nueve ni ocho materias si uno
no está bien consigo mismo
es por eso que quiero dejar atrás ese
anticuado concepto de la facultad es así
punto uno se la tiene que bancar uno lo
tiene que padecer no no no no no no no a
mí no vienen con eso porque la facultad
no tiene que ser un padecimiento la
facultad puede ser un disfrute
la verdad es que en estas hermosas
cuatro paredes podemos llegar a aprender
mucho más de lo que solo nos dicen los
libros y los cuadernos es por eso que
quiero comenzar a hablar no de carrera
universitaria sino de disfrute
universitario porque exigente por más de
que muchos digan lo contrario uno puede
disfrutar hacer una carrera
universitaria
1 perdonen la desprolijidad me van a
matar acá pero los tengo que dejar la
verdad es que mirando la hora me acordé
que tengo que hacer algo súper
importante y super impostergable
y no me malinterpreten --parciales tengo
en los jueves el lunes en la semana que
viene trabajos prácticos si mal no
recuerdo tengo uno el miércoles me
parece que todavía no lo prepare lo pot
lo impostergable y super importante que
tengo para hacer es cocinar un rico
bizcochuelo con mi madre no sé ustedes
pero a mí ya me ruge el estómago
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]